[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants décidément mirabel
et p'tit louis sont de plus en plus sage
j'espère que vous aussi vous faites
plaisir à vos parents et alors j'y vais
et d'accor asie gros ours mais ne soit
pas trop long un second prix souhaité
rocquemont toutes les caisses que c'est
qu'est-ce que tu ne très belle histoire
mais quelle histoire que je m'en vais
vous ont des causes que je venais près
de moi jack et le haricot
il y a très longtemps vivait dans un
petit village le pauvre
son fils le petit flacco
un jour sa maman dit à jako o mais notre
vieille match au marché et vend là nous
pourrons acheter de quoi manger
jacques au parti en chemin ils
rencontrent à un homme qui lui offrit
d'un sac de haricot en échange de sa
vache jacquot accepta sa maman entra
dans une grande colère petit idiot un
peu tu faire de cerny qu elle lança le
sac la fenêtre et blur a longtemps
longtemps notre jacotot cristal à se
coucher sans avoir mangé
le lendemain le soleil brillait jacquot
ouvrit la fenêtre et vie quant à ricco
avait fermé et poussé pendant la nuit et
montait vers le ciel en un clin d'oeil
jacquot trouve là à cheval sur une
branche est disparu dans les nuages
tandis que sa maman affolée la plaie en
vain
chacko arriva devant d'un très beau
château avec de grandes tours
toc toc toc il frappa à la porte
une dame lui triade derrière la porte
va-t'en petit garçon car le mato de ce
château est un ogre qui te mangera s'il
te vois déjà courant prend quand même et
se cacha sous la table son horloge sur
freud fille l'ogre mais la serveuse lui
servit très vite un coq rôti un figo et
un gros gâteau l'ogre mange à tous puis
il prit un arbre magique dit qu'à sa
poule de pondre et la poule pond 10,6
dormant puis
la harpe se mit à jouer une belle games
berceuses et langres se mit à ronfler
jacquot sorti de sa cachette et reporte
avec lui la poule et la harpe pour les
robes des savamment des arcs sont mis à
crier au secours au secours langue
serait vega avait couru derrière jacko
jacko deschamps dit le long du haricot
géant pris une hache et coup pas très
vite le pied de l'arbre le géant disparu
jacquot et sa maman vécurent très
longtemps riche et heureux grâce à la
poule et la harpe merveilleuse et voilà
l'histoire et finir mais dites nous
comment ils sont devenus riches et
comment ils furent heureux parce que
chaque fois qu'ils avaient besoin
d'argent
jouer dollar et la poule pour bell et
the en or dont il avait besoin pour
vivre
allons les enfants ou lit en vitesse une
lisse maintien recommandé de ne pas trop
traîner
voilà patron voit la jarrie j'ai encore
trouvé moyen de mettre en retard
[Musique]
voilà rien on est petit louis sonné
mirabel bonne nuit tous les enfants en
dormez vous vivez nous reviendrons vous
voir demain demain boni
[Musique]
on
où